ces conséquences de la crise sanitaire
au chapitre économique certaines
entreprises du cac 40 ont bénéficié des
aides de l'état comme le prêt garanti ou
le chômage partiel
et pourtant cela n'a pas dissuadé ces
groupes de licencier ou distribuer des
dividendes aux actionnaires dans des
proportions parfois impressionnantes
les explications de katia technique
selon l'observatoire des multinationales
en 2020 les entreprises du cac 40 ont
versé 140 % de leurs profits à leurs
actionnaires
c'est donc plus que ce qu'elles ont
engrangé alou montel trouver l'argent
est bien dans leur trésorerie problème
c'est qu'elles sont irrigués par des
fonds publics en effet avec la crise du
coville gouvernement français à
distribuer des aides massives pour
soutenir les entreprises grands groupes
inclus mais en retour peu de contrôle de
contrepartie ont été exigés le
gouvernement n'a pas demandé par exemple
d'engagement social environnemental ni
même l'arrêt de pratiques d'optimisation
fiscale
mais il y avait bien des garde-fous les
grandes entreprises bénéficiant des
aides de l'état devait s'engager à ne
pas verser de dividende en france ou à
l'étranger ni de racheter des actions en
2020 mais cela ne concernait que les
groupes d'au moins 5000 salariés ou dont
le chiffre d'affaires dépassé 1,5
milliard d'euros en france
les mailles du filet et est donc assez
large mais pour faire le bilan seuls
0,01 % des entreprises du cac 40 ont eu
recours au prêt d'état garantie c'est à
dire le fameux pge mais cela représente
tout de même 12,3 pour cent du montant
alloué
renault et air france conforama ou
lagardère pour ne citer qu'eux sont des
entreprises qui ont été aidées et qui
ont pourtant licenciés 27 groupes du cac
40 aurait profité du dispositif du
chômage partiel
malgré cette aide saison versé des
dividendes en 2020 et 22 en 2021 soit
80% d'entre elles l'observatoire des
multinationales dans ce dossier a
recensé 60 2500 suppressions d'emplois
dans le monde dont la moitié en france
et bien parmi les entreprises les plus
soutenus certaines ont pourtant
également licencié et pourtant elles ne
sont pas toutes en difficulté bien au
contraire cela
groupes du cac 40 ont eu des pertes ont
connu des pertes et du côté des
rémunérations la tendance est au beau
fixe cette dirigeants du cac 40 ont même
augmenté leur rémunération en 2020
malgré la crise du coc vide donc les
grands patrons et les actionnaires ont
su profiter de cet effet d'aubaine
inattendue de la pandémie